If every year 2.5% zakat on say are
there any signs of lead
mentioned in the hadith or the Quran?
There are signs mentioned authentic
hadith of but alhamdulillah all the
signs that are mentioned they are seen
after has passed. So it is the wisdom of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala. He does not
want us to know exactly because if you
had known then we have seen the sign and
then prayed and done worship and the
other nights we would have just you know
been a bit relaxed and not worship Allah
subhanaa tala. There's a hadith
mentioned in say Muslim that the
following of the next day the sun will
be without rays and it will appear like
a dish until it rises high. It's further
mentioned in Sai Muslim number two in
the book of fasting had number 2633
that the day following the sun will not
have rays and it's mentioned in say of
tabrani and
that the night of
will not be too hot neither will it be
too cold
and it will be a generous night a night
of happiness and
the
the next day after will appear weak and
reddish. So these are the signs Allah
subhananaa tala has mentioned in the say
but all of them there after the comes so
that we yet seek